Speaker 1: All right. I posted this to
my Twitter yesterday and so many people
were insanely triggered by it. As many of
you heard, former Democratic Congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard announced that she was leaving
the Democratic Party earlier this week. Not a
surprise. She's been a right wing reactionary
for a long time. She also started a podcast.
I came across it. It looks like she just
copied our logo. I mean, straight up.
It just looks like she copied our logo. We
have both logos up on the screen right now.
The David Pakman Show of the Tulsi Gabbard Show.
The concept is exactly the same as our logo. It is
a sort of square logo, slightly rectangular
with the and show in perfectly vertical non
italicized text. And then much like in our
logo where David Pakman is slightly italicized,
then at an angle, it's the exact same with
Tulsi Gabbard. Now I posted this to my Twitter.
70%, seriously, 30%. And just I mean, it's clearly
our logo. I'm not claiming to have a copyright on
slanted, italicized text. The tool stands or
tool sells or whatever you want to call them.
They went nuts coming out of the woodwork
saying, David, you're a shill. You don't
own copyright on italics. You're a disgusting
person. These folks are so triggered. Guys,
it's sort of a joke, but also it does
seem like someone copied our logo. Relax,
okay? We're just having a good time. And by the
way, the podcast, the Tulsi Gabbard podcast, it
sounds like Ben SHAPIRO. I mean, the idea that she
was genuinely a Democrat, it's a pathetic joke.